here with reaction author of the
bestseller power grab fox news
contributor jason Chaffetz along with
freedom caucus chairman new chairman
congressman Andy Biggs cars machay votes
I got to be honest this is taking way
too long Michael Horowitz is over 600
people we have been promised this again
and again and again there's no other
conclusion based on what we know then
there was premeditated fraud committed
on a FISA Court because it says verified
on the top of a FISA application we know
now that it was unverifiable based on
the steel dossier as the Grassley Graham
memo says why so long and will it be
what Sarah just said I think Sarah is
absolutely right I don't think you can
justify it going on this long
I think anything past Thanksgiving is
highly suspicious I do think that
originally there was an anticipation
that as much as 20% of the report would
be redacted
now the anticipation is that it would be
sentences and paragraphs not nearly the
20% that originally people thought and I
also think it's going to now envelope in
people outside the Department of Justice
people like John Brennan and others into
other agencies and I think that will be
as we look back the reason why it took
months and months longer because this
tangled web was much further and deeper
than just the people at the Department
of Justice and I also think it will show
how they manipulated and used the media
here in the United States to move
forward a political agenda at those at
the top at the FBI and Congressman Andy
Biggs we really don't have any ambiguity
here because we already know the bulk of
information in that those applications
three of them signed by Jim Comey three
of them was based on unverifiable
material we also know that everybody was
warned that number one still had an
anti-trump bias that Hillary paid for it
and they were all warned it wasn't
verified so there really is no other
possible conclusion so then the next
question is do you see crimes here and
who would you expect should you know now
that I guess
has you know this is a criminal
investigation the right to subpoena
convene grand juries and press charges
who would you expect might be facing
that and in near future well I'm I'm
concerned for people like McCabe Comey
even rod Rosenstein anybody who signed
off Sally Yates anybody who signed off
on one of those FISA warrant
applications I'm concerned that they I'm
not really concerned I I believe that
they're culpable in some way I also
believe that their sources are culpable
anybody who suppressed information but
you know part of this sean is and the
reason that I think this got delayed so
very much is remember what Horowitz did
the last report he did which gave us
people like McCabe struck and page he
kept getting whistleblower information
at the last minute so we've been
promised this report for literally
months which tells me that he had to
broaden the scope of his investigation
and I think there's going to be a world
of people perhaps even Brennan perhaps
even clapper the highest levels of the
intelligence community I think are
potentially culpable here all right
thank you both for that report we
appreciate